mm it's silent Bob let me get in close
well you really use this P Papa I don't
pop my keys I'll keep them to myself
here we are ladies and gentlemen on a
day that none of us thought we'd ever
get to ten years sober what an
accomplishment that is think about what
you like to do in life right now think
about the things make you happy what do
you do especially as we're all locked
down to unwind to let off steam
now imagine somebody was like you can't
do that anymore for the rest of your
life that's every day of this kid's life
he wakes up and he wants to do the thing
that like where he could let off steam
but he don't do it why for everyone else
for for his wife for his kid for me for
everybody about him that is selfless
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] indeed mother mother
[ __ ] it's a selfless act that he does
he makes a choice every day to not [ __ ]
it up for everybody else but essentially
[ __ ] it up for himself because you would
like to be able to party like everybody
else but he puts it away and asked to
forever man I thank you for that because
he did that it's coming up on the 10
year birthday of Jay and Silent Bob get
old we've been doing that podcast for
like 10 years and that led to Jay and
Silent Bob reboot so his sobriety comes
with huge benefits so it's a big day in
our world if were we not all terrified
and hiding from COBIT we'd be on a stage
somewhere this is a momentous occasion
we've been talking about the 10 year
sober party for the shows for get old
for a long time years going like where
will we do it what massive venue what
5,000 seater can we pack and [ __ ] and
that's not the case but here we are
we're hanging out here and I think we
might be doing a Jay and Silent Bob get
old online streaming this weekend if not
this weekend next weekend we'll let you
know when it's happening yeah but how'd
I ever mind me [ __ ] me in the mouth
how do you feel on your sober birthday
we good it's been good again oh sorry we
it's been good and again I'm sorry guys
I it's my bad I really need to get the
two mics going I've not figured out
we're gonna get it eventually eventually
it's gonna be so perfect Kevin's never
gonna want to leave
Hollywood money and one tiny ass Mike
makes no sense but I feel good cuz we
started we chatted for a while we I
played a little bit of games and my god
later I'm gonna do some look I got this
racing wheel I don't know if you noticed
it here there's a racing wheel so I
might play some racing like it hours and
hours from now after you and I do our
stuff and then I was going to have maybe
an injustice tournament I figured maybe
we could even we get maybe do one if he
wants to before you meet what we're in
justice you played that we don't wanna
fight you I'm a lover not a fighter yes
we could do that somebody has to really
good question and then it went by let me
see
it's coming from our old friend bounine
ista says Jaime is I have a very
ignorant question this ain't ignorant
there's a good question does Kevin's
4/20 life me smoking weed impact you in
any way is it a challenge or is it one
of the 12 steps intended to prevent it
being an issue like when a person is on
a diet but everyone else is eating and
undulating so is it tough for me smoking
weed does that have an effect no no it's
it's it's actually fine for me because I
do like weed weed is what was yeah what
we was one of my things I enjoyed a lot
but it was never something that I craved
so much that like if I ran out of weed I
wouldn't be like oh my god bro let me
get twenty dollars I need $20 to get a
bag of weed same with booze I like booze
and I dress
so again it it just luckily it's not
weed and alcohol is not something that I
crave so much that it bothers me I
actually am glad he doesn't I've know
probably doing it because I'm all for
weed I think it makes people calm I
think people like my mom who is sick who
couldn't hold food down in her stomach
because of all the pills she smoked she
they gave her pop pills and it made her
the whole food down my buddy who passed
a long time ago same with him so I think
there's many good uses for marijuana so
I'm all for it and it doesn't bother me
at all
now if he was like blowing lines of like
heroin and crack that might be a
different story but but yeah luckily
that's not the case so no it doesn't
impact me it doesn't affect me if
anything I'd like push them all Mike
I'll go buy you sell em and get it to
you not that that's ever the case or I
need to but I'm just saying that's how
easy it is he had boots we hit all your
keys the all right so while we're on the
twitch platform right here maybe is
there a way to like because this is kind
of for those here on twitch I'm sure a
lot of you knew
Byron Bernstein reckful or at least knew
his work he passed
he's a big twitcher and he'd be passed
away so he's trending right now on
Twitter our heart goes out to his
friends family and fans you know people
liked watching him do his thing
he was very hopeful guy yes bummer so
but that's you know just there's also
again you know there's I think you met
him at a twitch card once you and Jordan
doctor disrespect there's a bunch of
this is a different story though doctor
yeah I did play in a tournament with dr.
disrespect but he was thrown off the
platform
or I'm not thrown off I don't know what
happened but he was asked to leave or
they blocked him or whatever but but
yeah
Byron a big big hero to a lot of people
I don't know how much I'm supposed to
say but here let's let's put it this way
mental health matters kids if you have
friends that feel down some people
cannot get out of the funk I mean it has
everything to do with their your
chemistry your body chemistry whoo I've
trained as a hype train but reach out to
your friends particularly in this time
as we're all trapped inside and
separated from one another
being social helps a person's well-being
mental well-being being isolated not
good for people so reach out to folks we
don't want to let people slip through
the cracks man is bummer all right but
the good news in this room today is that
didn't happen with our kid here man
there were days that we didn't know if a
man was gonna make it I remember him
saying at one point was one of the
saddest things I heard him saying to me
I'm going if I'm still like this when
I'm 30 years old was a 30 or 40 and then
you moved the date up he said if I'm
like still like this when I'm 30 I'm
gonna kill myself I said what are you
talking about he goes I can't live like
this with the addiction and stuff like
that you've got five tier one subs and a
hundred percent on the hype train that's
worth living for so when he said that to
me I was like heartbroken I'm like oh my
god you're true American original one of
the funniest people I know one of the
sweetest most artful people I know man
he's all heart and [ __ ] no head
obviously but all heart and to hear that
- hear that battle with his addiction
that he was so like you know I I can't
live the rest of my life like this that
always made me sad
then one day like we were always on his
ass about like you gotta clean up ever
we took him to rehab many times he one
day just made the decision as opposed to
everyone else going you gotta you gotta
and it changed everything for everybody
like you know we could be sitting here
right now or we wouldn't be sitting here
right now if Jason didn't choose
sobriety because the
we probably would have lost him you know
he did some hard drugs not the easy
civil wasn't just sitting around smoking
weed so for him to be here is a minor
miracle of sorts I you know it's been 10
years plus since he was the guy that was
like oh my god [ __ ] him and the drugs
again and [ __ ] so it's been so long and
it's like honestly hard to remember you
know the feeling of what it was like
when you were so like desperate for your
friend to get clean because he's been
clean for so long but again man like he
saved his own life sometimes that's what
you you got to do especially when your
demons get the better of you so a good
thing that you're here hopefully you
don't get thrown off twitch someone
asked this is Austin really a prick in
real life for those watching son and
lock down on TBS no Austin is an
incredibly sweet kid he's playing a
hundred and eighty degrees away from who
he is in real life
Jay got to work with them like in the
last episode that was up and Jay was
always like kind of like Jays more he
gets more like what the [ __ ] why she
datin a boy like then I do and stuff I'm
like cuz that's what people do so he he
was always very like I want to meet this
guy I don't like that he's living there
so then when he worked on him on the
short he's like I like him he's a good
guy so I got to know him instead alright
hypetrain level 2 we got 2 minutes and
41 seconds we have to take the hype
train today ladies and gentlemen the
hype is real for this [ __ ] kid right
here and I'll tell you what if I've
trained now is crawling if the hype
train takes us all the way to the
highest level today
we got some fun stuff we're gonna open
boxes man I got some Masters of the
Universe stuff to open up Mattel sent me
some stuff oh yeah you're gonna see some
of that we got some other stuff to open
up but only if the hype train takes us
where we want to go two minutes ladies
and gentlemen oh look at the big jump
man was it smoke uh three just gifted
five tier one subs how awesome and the
hype train pulls into the station nine
percent one more percent we're gonna be
done with level dude when it's done
ladies and gentlemen you did it the hype
train has brought us to level three as
it builds let's check out some of these
questions that we're getting now I have
the mic I'm in control
see this feels right this feels right
kids be honest with you man I need this
in my life
[ __ ] surrounded by five monitors
talking into a microphone looking at
camera I feel like my character from
live free or die hard the warlock the
basement full of like high-tech gear and
stuff let's see we got Trey Moxa's keV I
gave up sowed three of Sun unlocked down
four to five stars it was funny
but it wasn't amusing at all I believe I
saw your comment that's right Jason's
not in that episode but he's in the next
one which we shot two days ago so you'll
get more Jay Mewes action he couldn't
make it for the other one cuz he was
doing all this stuff but now he's back
in the show he is like our wacky
neighbor character for heaven's sakes
let's see
get-get-get to the boat says Kevin I
just want to thank you for being a cool
guy when I saw you speak years ago thank
you since then I've stopped being a cool
guy now I'm a total [ __ ] you wouldn't
recognize me
I'm kidding holy [ __ ] hot train got into
level three laser John we've got Jason
Mewes here
[ __ ] him it's his show and the hype
train is being conducted by me whoa whoa
we're gonna level for lazy Gemma level
three is complete that's a memory a
distant memory who couldn't even
remember level three because now all of
us are on level four in the hype is
building building for Jason Mewes sober
birthday ten years sober today it's
amazing okay
get to the boat says I wanna thank you
for being a cool guy when I saw you
speak two years ago there was a double
feature at the Prince Charles cinema in
London I love the Prince Charles cinema
that's my home away from home when we're
in England that's where we do all our
shows and screenings such a great venue
man you did a Q&A afterwards and stayed
for hours answering questions it was a
great experience thank you
was that the show where at the end of it
I was like I got weed
left over and I'm getting on a plane in
the morning so everyone meet me outside
I'll give away my weed and then I went
you know then everyone left and I went
backstage and the folks that run the
theater were like you can't do that bro
like that is legit against the law and I
was like what to give weed away I'm not
selling tour like you're not even
supposed to have weed in this country I
was like I'm not oh heavens so I didn't
get to give the weed away kids at the
theater though they met a lot bandits
hopefully that doesn't mean I can't go
back to England but like we heard you
like the marijuana ultimate weapon age
says sober - man keep fighting the good
fight love you both
he needs that kind of support man that's
what's got him here I'll tell you you
know in the beginning when we started
doing Jay and Silent Bob get old that
was a real help for Jason to get sober
and stay sober sitting out there talking
about it and then we travel around and
stuff do live show made money from him
one night we're sitting in a house that
Jay bought with James and Bob get old
money so your support of the show was
absolutely wonderful but the the hold on
where is it so I forgot what it was keep
fighting a good fight so he you know I
don't know point is he's sober still
let's see hey the new iron Bob funkopop
looks way looks great Jake Congrats on
your 10 years so proud of you man this
is gasser Oney Bona needs to just gifted
100 Tier one subs doing 100 and that
took the hog train to level five Bona
B's - did it single-handedly she took
the controls from eights like that
Denzel Washington movie in the Train
that's tremendous man Bonin Easter says
without being too grim Cortney
retrospectively thought that maybe had
they not done an intervention and let
Kurt make the decision to stay himself
maybe things would be different it all
comes down to the one person the one
person has to decide she talked about
Kurt Cobain and Courtney left you're
absolutely right that's been my
experience I mean I tried to make Jay
get sober for like a lot what is this
425 percent
so we're ready level five you guys are
magical man you took us to level five
from a man's birthday
that means the world bounine Easter yet
single-handedly took us there boning me
as well as everyone else let's see what
else we got little screen scroll down
and that means definitely we're gonna be
opening up some toys no [ __ ] man
yeah yeah
scrolling down look wow we were way
there you go you show me you learned me
teach me teacher four hundred thirty
percent on the hype train kids that's
phenomenal man Harley Quinn e85 26 was
playing a game on my phone
named dragon city and named one of my
dragons Jay Mewes yes look at that
somebody asked about the iron Bob Funko
pop it is phenomenal Funko pop announced
all their San Diego comic-con 2024 pops
and one of them is iron Bob and if you
ever seen Jay and Silent Bob reboot and
if you're watching this why the [ __ ]
haven't you yet there's a moment in the
movie where the director Kevin Smith
goes like I can't wait till they make em
a Funko pop and now they did my dream
has come true everything is right with
the world a little piece of plastic I
haven't felt so good about a piece of
plastic since I bought a flashlight man
this is phenomenal but I ain't gonna
[ __ ] iron Bob I'll tell you that right
now what's in the box on YouTube and two
things you said what's in the box
because I don't know how many years that
was five years ago six seven yeah and
you said you said man you'd be awesome
the way you play with toys you'd be an
awesome father
so you foreshadow that I was gonna have
a kid and then you also said the voice
we'd open up oxes hater tots you're like
you said something about working he was
the voice of teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle
I think what's his name detonator
thoughts
[Music]
did hate okay fred armisen yes what
about I said something about Fred I will
point out though you did have a kid when
we sued at once in a box
totally totally but she was not like
playable like you know video game she
was little and just like doing that [ __ ]
so she grew up and I think it still
holds where I was like you're gonna be
great dad
cuz you do play with like the kid now
the kid and Jay are like [ __ ] this
it's goddamn adorable she better they
are best [ __ ] friends I can't believe
we're already done with our hype train I
thought we were gonna have to yeah
really push that single handily up the
hill I think I can't spocky lip says
happy 10 years Jay Mewes you're an
amazing inspiration so glad I got to see
you guys a few years ago at the
Lexington comic and toy Con I was the
artist that gave you guys the poppets do
you remember the poppets did you get the
[ __ ] stink war stuff stink or down
that's shirts this is a lady who made
for you Jay and Silent Bob reboot like
remember the felt ones that I have in my
house but she also made you a stink war
and it's got a snoo goons cap because he
plays stink or in in our forthcoming
Masters of the Universe show which may
be a great time to segue how about we
get into a little old-school what's in
the box kids would you like that okay
I see Leo cello boy Jake says I've been
tuned into the get old podcast since it
started unbelievable stories and
insights along the way can't believe the
way he sounded then too the way things
are now it's absolutely true if you're
really curious go listen to an episode
of Jay and Silent Bob get old and like
maybe one of the first five and then
come watch Jay do a stream he's become a
wreck and tour as they say it's
absolutely amazing so well done Jay
you two are still bonkers and the story
continues and I'm so happy this is the
case will you come back to the UK for a
tour when all this Kovac [ __ ] is over
please
absolutely oh my god and you'll be sure
you see us at the Prince Charles theatre
when we're there but I went over for Jay
and Silent Bob reboot right around the
holidays right around Christmas or
something like that right before
Christmas because I got to see all the
Christmas decorations up in London is
beautiful there's great people there and
you know what we all speak English so it
was very easy to understand people in a
foreign land man it was cool so
hopefully we get back to England as soon
as possible I think today is the six
year anniversary of the show that me and
you did and me and Ralph did at the
Hammersmith Apollo in London that was
like a six thousand [ __ ] seater and
we sold it out where-where-where loopy
five five not please say hi to me Kevin
loopy where you been all right let's see
what other cats are saying Matt
Westphalen points out hey where eff keV
today is kendra that's his wife and his
17th wedding anniversary congratulations
when I renewed their vows years ago that
was the first time we ever met Matt
Westphalen yeah I'll tell you who's
getting laid today Matt Westphalen oh
yeah he's gonna be knee-deep in there
man as an anniversary is the only time
married people ever get laid and stuff
is his anniversary today so he's gonna
have sex with me I said you gotta wait
till your anniversary
I remember once saying like he was like
moves can we [ __ ] it on yeah
if you're ever sober ten years I'll [ __ ]
you today's the day I didn't realize
he'd do it so now we have to have
[ __ ] sex um Linda from Jersey says
I've been a fan for 26 years my god
thank you I just want to say thank you
both for entertaining me and everyone
else for so long Congrats on ten years
sober J and we're so glad you're doing
well Kevin thanks for including me much
love man Kevin will we see mo two
automatics two not just toys st. Vincent
coke says or says Vincent Coke if I do
that I'm gonna lose the job man you know
what I'm saying and I've enjoyed this
job I mean like don't get me wrong the
money's nice or whatever but the work is
phenomenal I'm telling
cats are gonna love this series when you
get to see it next year it's it's
thrilling it's adventure it's poignant
it's nostalgic
it's fun it's funny in places but it is
heartbreaking as well is emotional ride
you know for a bunch of tooken
characters that were based on toys
before it was even a cartoon so I'm
telling you man our marching orders were
like make it as serious as Shakespeare
make it like [ __ ] use these characters
until she experienced story and I think
we did I think so far so good
great cast including Lena Headey as
evil-lyn Mark Hamill as Skeletor Sarah
Michelle Gellar orgalorg Geller Gellar
has always called her Sarah Michelle be
honest I always called her Buffy behind
her back I think the rest of the world
there but now I'm working with her I
have to call her Sarah Michelle can't
call her Buffy that being salting I'd be
like her calling me son Bob which I'll
be honest with you I would [ __ ] love
if she did she's wonderful we just
recorded her back few episodes with her
the other day she's so [ __ ] OnPoint
it's great
Chris Wood of course and if no one else
can Chris Wood is our amazing he-man
slash Adam spoilers in case you didn't
know that He Man and Adam Prince Adam
were the same person
and of course liam Cunningham from Game
of Thrones man The Onion Knight he plays
our man-at-arms Steven root plays
Cringer Tiffany Smith plays Andra and
she's phenomenal the cast cross the
boards Griffin who plays Griffin Newman
plays Orko if this man don't win an Emmy
[ __ ] this business he is beyond
brilliant and a little secret about his
Oracle performance when the original
Orko was one of the Filmation guys one
of the guys that ran the company he
recorded voice then they pitch his voice
up you know in post like make it all
high like Orko Griffin Newman sat down
in front of a mic and busted his Orko
voice which is very similar sounding
without post effect so he's just doing
it himself you know what that means that
means that any kid meets him they could
be he's like I'm Orko and they'll be
like do it and he could literally do it
without being like wow there's a lot of
post-production effects on that and
stuff like that
I thought that was so beautiful for the
rest of his life little kids will be
able to be like Bjork oh and he can be
Orko just like that and of course not
the least of all those actors is Jay
Mewes playing good old stink or for the
first time ever they didn't well I'm not
first time ever first time in our store
I think they did in the Mike Young
stories but he was never he was created
for the old he-man cartoon well for the
Mattel line of toys but he the the
cartoon was over they cancelled it
before they got to include stinker
so we're sequel izing the original
cartoon run we love the mike young thing
from like early 2000s but this is a
direct sequel til to the Filmation stuff
and J gets to finally give voice to
stinker and is a [ __ ] a good job made
me laugh in the actual show okay let's
shall we open some boxes let's bring
those box up buona nice toises J
remember to show Kevin the infinity war
Captain America from weeks ago so he can
see the articulation velcro muff says
hey guys you really think a flick with
the bomb and phantoms I guess it's been
20 to 23 years so I could probably
answer this honestly finally yes that's
why I wrote that line in Jay and Silent
Bob strike back and Ben says that it is
like the bane of his existence because
he'll be out in the world and people
will be like Affleck you're the bomb and
phantoms yo and [ __ ] like that he's like
I can always tell your fans they scream
at me from across the street um let's
see Jay Mewes crowd crowd boos will
crowd crop balls nice says how much are
you charging Kevin Smith take-up Mike
ton I know I had to pay him I was just
like please dude I'll give you a hundred
bucks I'll suck your dick let me rock
your mic please I love doing this I've
said it before I say it a million times
over coming here is like going to Vegas
because like there's people and lights
and Bing Bing Bing and [ __ ] like the
I drain and we won and I don't even know
what we want so [ __ ] awesome we are
up to eleven hundred and twenty-four
viewers man
we was started when I joined at 400
we're up to 11 24 everyone coming in to
wish Jay a happy silver birthday
wondering where the [ __ ] Jay Mewes is
there is he's Tucker now he's a putter
in Ron's office he is he's talking about
he's like I feel warm that's because
he's an old man he's getting like the
[ __ ] vapors he's probably going
through menopause that's right music
pause all right here beside or which
side feels like slide the table up I can
move the camera if you like but it's up
to you so we could do this this badass
and you stand behind it yeah unlike
behind behind it yeah but maybe you need
a chair and we take one box down and
then you sit in the chair and then you
can look over the box as we open up you
got a knife son yeah very nice yes yes
it is spin this box around looks like
yeah all the way around just got my
address like Blair or the world shape
and it's not like you can find me on the
internet like literally but you know
let's not make it super easy that's okay
don't let's see that all right here we
go man welcome to what's in the box
I'm Skeletor nice and we are going to do
what we do best
he has the power so he's gonna take the
sword of power he's got jam it into this
box
rip it the [ __ ] open just like he-man
did back in the old quarter know you
have the power just don't cut me with
that ow
we got happy is let's see what it is you
pull it up
we're going to see some [ __ ] kids
punched mega constructs Castle Grayskull
Oh bring it up to cameras so it's mega
constructs Masters of the Universe
oh it's Castle Grayskull turn the box
around so they can see the characters
everything here show them not me I'm
unfamiliar with he-man the goddess
sorceress man-at-arms Calot or beast man
the goddess is Teela or is it evil in
its working elevator oh my lord I mean
I'm glad they got the sorceress but how
do you not have Teela
I honestly think that's meant to be
teleca's the first incarnation of Teela
I believe either Teela or evil and she
was green like this I think it was Teela
because she was called warrior goddess
in the beginning yes so this is the
early incarnation of Teela so this I
know my mo - this is so true - mo - that
they went with the old care of the first
incarnation of Teela which was the
goddess I love seeing that they've
included sorceress as well and and it
looks like there's a little door over
there all of these characters I'm happy
to report the goddess is Teela are in
our masters in the universe series so
you build it like you would build an
another block system don't mention the
name yes yes mega constructs is the one
that put this out so piece by piece you
put them together and then you build a
grace gone three thousand five hundred
eight pieces man this will take you some
time to put together so if you open the
box it don't look like this you got to
make it look like a make
like so if you open the box is just a
bunch of pieces a bunch of bags what is
it this is that six six people no I
wonder where aged six and up yeah I D
that means how many how many characters
are there 1 2 3 4 5 6 yes your six
characters I guess they're saying six
people can play this that's pretty
[ __ ] dope let's show them the top
picture man yeah got yourself again
that's meant to be - I bet it's the
goddess
beast man sorceress man-at-arms and
figure as a classic piece of MO - right
there punch a bunch of I love how they
built like you can see there's they're
like chamber the seat and then you got
the jail cells a bunch of weapon racks
ladder I mean this would be a nice build
if anyone likes Legos remember I don't
know if this is your mega instructs you
guys like building things then I don't
know we're able to give some of these
away again we only have one of them so
it's up to you it's your sober birthday
do you want this Masters of the Universe
and mega constructs that Mattel was kind
enough to send us to open up or do you
want to give it to somebody out there
well see we'll see how much we'll see
how much love there is for something
like this that someone might not have it
will do that because yes it would be fun
for me to build as well on my stream
month on Tuesdays but the man's life is
all about sacrificing sacrifices is need
to do drugs every day and I see your
silver birthday so he'll sacrifice this
to a fan if they really like it enough
you let us know in the chat we've got to
tell us let me see mmm whoo I can't ask
any question because people just go to
the internet and find it out tell me
tell us tell him it's a show why you
feel like you deserve that mega
constructs Castle Grayskull the best
answer if it's if it is the best answer
then it'll be you versus J and then
he'll have to make the deciding call
what an unnecessarily complicated
[ __ ] it's just fun now yeah we will make
it fun so it'll be a lot more fun than a
[ __ ] sounded CP TP 283 says reboot is
killing it over here on TV in the UK
thank you that's right Jane song Bob
reboot is on I think it's now TV and a
big sky as well over in the UK um props
to you guys props to both of you guys
why thank you
Congrats Jay huge accomplishment on ten
years Kevin are we gonna see a clerks
three no our version and a color version
Logan that [ __ ] up son that's funny so
will I do a black and white and a color
the because of what the storyline is
you're gonna get both that's all I'll
say very cryptic they did a poll on
should I keep it or give it oh look at
this there's a poll should Muse keep it
right now 158 votes for 96 percent of
the vote says yes and then four percent
five percent says no I want it so so far
everyone wants to give it to you for
your birthday how sweet is that man I'd
say I'm really proud of Jay Mewes says k
for kick kills for this huge milestone
in his life I'm really proud of you
Kevin as well for being there for your
friend much love you both I mean not for
nothing but it's like I got nothing
without him if he had talked and become
an addict and died from it stuff you
know and Silent Bob doesn't work you
need Jay in front of it and stuff so I'm
uh you know it ain't me man is all him
he does the heavy lifting it's easy for
me to be like be sober and him go like
okay but every day he's got to make the
choice so he's the he's a real hero here
he's a hero because he saved his own
life all right let's see is there MJ
says there any way to get those movie
boxes and price leaves without leaving
quarantine right now if you go to movies
pop up calm if you're in the Los Angeles
area post mates will deliver it to you
but I can't say anything yet but I will
say this soon even if you're not in Los
Angeles you may be able to enjoy some
movies watch my Comic Con panel
you know Comic Cons been cancelled this
year sadly but we're doing it online so
watch my formerly Hall H Comic Con panel
when Comic Con hits man and I'll have a
bunch of information bunch of new
information for you including some fun
stuff about movies but Derek and the
good folks at
by the max killing it with the movies
papa some people asked like wait I
thought heard Los Angeles just shut
everything down again we were fine
because we we were not in Donny an
in-room dining experience you come in to
pick up your food you can take pictures
and stuff but nobody's eaten in the
restaurant so we were completely
unaffected smoovies wide open man if
you're here anywhere near Los Angeles
come visit it's great go to movies pop
up calm but if you can't reach us and
you're looking to have some of these
things like the price leaves and whatnot
stick around there's gonna be some good
information for you don't matter where
you are in the world okay let's see what
else we got Jay Mewes what's your
gamertag would love to game with you
says children Betty beating you they're
gonna put it in the chat there's all for
all the different games all my different
tags for blizzard battle battlenet epic
all that stuff word oh wait says Kevin
Smith twitch channel when then I know I
have a twitch channel I just don't I'm
not as engaged as he is and I love being
on his he's got all set up [ __ ] super
sweet right now 315 people say you
should keep Castle Grayskull and 15
people said [ __ ] you I want it even on
your birthday alright Jay he's got a
knife he is about to stab the [ __ ] out
of this second box that's coming from
the good folks at Mattel let's see what
we got in that box Jason Mewes I want
thank Adam for sending up I'm sorry
I want to thank Andrew for sending this
stuff out from Mattel thank you Andrew
for sending this [ __ ] ooh there's a
budget [ __ ] in this one alright let's do
them one at a time I'm gonna reach back
and and do I'm gonna do these alright
it's a boy it's a box full of joy kids
so let's do him piece by piece number
one we've got the mega constructs Prince
Adam figure so that's what's in the box
the big get right here's Prince Adam who
else you got oh there she is evil Lynch
she's not represented in the box but
this is another mega constructs figure
that
you could put into your castle grayskull
playset boom Oh
faker faker um another cat all these
cats are in my series man is so awesome
alright who else ah there she is
Tina Tina its she's represented as the
goddess I'm on the castle grayskull mega
constructs but here she's flat-out tila
herself man Sarah Michelle Oh Oh moss
man Moss man's new G bujji's moss man in
our series is portrayed looking real
close get close lost man is portrayed by
alan oppenheimer i'm pretty sure that
sounds mean who did the voice of
Skeletor throughout the entire run of
the Filmation series so he brought him
back and he does the voice of moss man
in this so he's still part of it all
what else you going oh there's another
cat who I know
Stratos he gets his own mega constructs
figures man were you uh masters universe
kid when you were little or do you have
any money no I watched your cartoons of
course but I didn't know it like you
know I didn't get to watch it as often
as I would like but you didn't buy the
toys right no there's two different toys
two different designs how interesting
there's two evil lens so and they're two
but both bought mega constructs but
completely different in design of
package and in color of the figure
actually how strange I mean I now you
know got to get them all okay and then
here's our this of course there he is
with the hammock staff Rand are you
blathering boob a 2-pack oh [ __ ] with a
guy of course man he-man doesn't seem as
logical but a man versus beast man I
would have done a man versus Skeletor
he-man verse beast man and the mega
constructs fingers man let's see what
the audience is saying about our figure
reads
how do you do the thing we go to the
boundary yeah I just keep going and when
you get right to the bottom you gotta
just go slow cuz otherwise it like keeps
going it's weird
Skeletor is I am cuts that Skeletor is
just wah wah Luigi after he found a
magic staff where were you when I was
right masters universe I could have used
the material like that kb/s says where's
battle cat excellent question
excellent question where's the battle
cat you got something to show us unbox
jay with these with the constant mega
construct I love are they at the castle
but now they're adding all these pits
and here's this prize in Oh they've got
wrote ons man holy crap it's battle cat
versus Roton so you get two you get two
flat-out play by a whiff battle cat you
got a he-man
you got a wrote on and that's mur man
why would he be in a row time but still
badass here's what they look like on the
outside I'm happy to report wrote ons
wrote ons and is that a talent fighter
from another set more to collect who
this is dope once again from good folks
at mega constructs battle cat versus
wrote on and it's it's mer man in the
wrote on it's a wind Raider mega
constructs presents the wind Raider
ladies and gentlemen and this I believe
this is a classic is a classic box art
no its roots brand-new box art this wind
Raider comes with both a man and
Skeletor very dope that's how they get
around in Eternia the wind Raider
breaking wind Raiders and Thor and point
dread holy [ __ ] man yeah but it's also
really [ __ ] cool like they did point
dread and the Talon fighter and they did
Panther which for those who don't know
that is skeletor's battle
cat how awesome it really is and we have
all these characters in our show as well
man oh man I'm glad to see that we're
very much in keeping with all the
product man in terms of like we're using
all the locations we're using all the
toys all the characters one more piece
which is last piece from he-man oh it's
a box of all the mega constructs 5 micro
action figures to collect and these look
a little different thank you oh it's
yeah this goes on the ear open it up it
goes on the counter right cool it there
like it's a point of purchase like what
do they call that like last thing you
see and you're like oh [ __ ] I want that
yeah open that [ __ ] up man it's [ __ ]
masters universe tours are dope dope I
can't believe they call it Pantera and
point dread like you ever collected this
stuff back in the day it's nice to see
that they're keeping it alive here while
Jay opens that let's go see what folks
thought of what we bought what we bought
what we thought michaelis is Kevin have
you already talked about release date I
missed the beginning of the livestream I
used to have battle cat release date no
they haven't given a release date yet
but it's definitely 2021 probably by
this time next year I will imagine I
don't know anything for a fact but I
will imagine you might have seen it by
now I think by the by July of next year
I would hope it's out but if not we'll
be talking about at a comic-con next
year let's see looking forward to
masters universe I had all the og toys
said avoid the noid well I haven't heard
that word and a lot of that term avoid
the no heed who is it
somebody f MF to Hollywood says Kevin
and Jay I need a Jane
Sam Bob orsk universe constructs art I'm
with you man that'd be amazing well
[ __ ] look at this so it's a full box
in them it's like when you're at the
counter and your kids like or Jason
Mewes is like that's awesome man
thank you to Andrew and good folks at
Mattel we're sending over some some cool
[ __ ] now what you're gonna keep it all
on play with it
educate your kid so that it's an awesome
thing that of course I feel like if you
have the castle you almost want to keep
all of these pieces
no definitely feel like there's plenty
of figures I can give away and I think I
should give a couple of these pieces I
mean I could give these away
individually or at least a couple
because one person getting one of these
probably like cool but rickety chaos
said my seven-year-old son wants that
Skeletor castle to know how much does
that lego Skeletor castle cost on the
market hopefully it's not expensive but
so I'm gonna save up get it for him I
don't know they don't tell us what
anything cost you do know how much it
cost yeah let's go I mean again Game
Stop by me might have been marking it up
because they might have bought it and
then they're trying to resell it but
that the the game stopped by me they
were selling it for 350 what $350 yeah
what do you want to keep it but they
might have marked it up don't get me
wrong so maybe it's maybe we get it from
like the place where they originally
sell it maybe 200 it's definitely at
least 200 I know that egghead gamer 89
says congratulations jack I just want to
say I've been a huge fan for so long
also what was it like that close to
katie Morgan I have dreamed of being
Lester aka Pete Jones what was it like
to do that scene in Jay and samba Zack
and Miri Make a Porno with Katie Morgan
where you were like that sauce spa
number one Katie's a wonderful kid like
I miss that kid she's an adult like but
she's younger than us but she's
absolutely wonderful got a wonderful big
heart light light of the world and stuff
good for you guys can you hear me at
least in up there so we don't the move
but she was great she made it easy
because it was really uncomfortable for
me I never had done scenes like that I
never done
work like that on camera where I had to
pretend knapsacks and pretend to do
stuff being that I was half naked I just
had a sock covering my bits uh she made
it awesome what was it like I don't know
for me I she was like at the time I
don't know I guess it was she was sort
of dating a friend so it made it sort of
weird and afterwards she started dating
each other and I was married so it
didn't matter you I don't know if you
remembered yet but you were dating
Jordan but yeah oddly enough
movie sex is not like hot at all it's
like you know everyone's Stan you've got
literally 25 30 people pointing lights
and cameras and microphones at you and
stuff like that
and they're like all right pretend it's
awkward that's why I've never done a
movie yeah I guess my wife in a movie
and Jay and Silent Bob reboot and even
that was hard well I was hard gem girl
1975 says Castle the great great Castle
Grayskull is on Amazon right now for
around 160 bucks oh that's a better
price too that's way more expensive than
I thought it would be I'm not like
saying it should be cheaper but like wow
that's I didn't know one sixties a lot
more issues how much is like Legos go
for and [ __ ]
they that expensive they're about that
much was that Death Star well the Death
Star was special oh the Death Star's was
300 what and if they're discontinued
they're more by taking away all your
freedom but basically all these except
rate can't see behind me these are about
about 160 to about 300 but again I think
again maybe it was 250 that I saw but
again I think they marked it up but
still I was right after tax and stuff
your earth shipping you know maybe 200
but hopefully that young man can't get
it for his voice for 20 radio gaming
says it's a pleasure to meet my hero in
writing hello Kevin how's it brother
it's so well man my friends alive after
10 years of battling drug addiction
staying sober he reached his 10-year
silver birthday so it's a it's a
celebration [ __ ] to steal from Dave
Japan so awesome
that we're here hanging out open that
bag yes said they sent with that
envelope I'm curious to see okay I got
it I got it the topic oh I love you guys
so much says Dragonslayer thank you
lunchbox three three three says [ __ ]
drugs and alcohol I'm with movies pop
calm they make new movies brand new
little movies with our tags and movie
tag Jay and Sam Bob tagging inside it
says I mean Lee Jeannette made these
good folks at Legion out there so
they're selling these right now movies
pop up calm and you got a kid or you're
just like I'm a big fan of that big
count and look at this this is the shirt
on the back it's you know the stickers
on the floor at the movies pop up in
West Hollywood to keep social distancing
it says maintain social distancing keep
one cow apart at least six feet so
that's what's on the floor at movies so
this is the back of this shirt turning
around the front of the shirt as a
movies logo orange and purple ladies a
jump you got like those colors to be in
the movie that's for sure another movie
sure we got there I ate it movies with
tears and I just filled the gun remember
that yeah remember that Jane's I'm Bob
Jack back yeah did a purple one yes
purple we should make one where they put
that sticker is facing sticker on the
front rather than the back I make it
makes sense put it on the back of
somebody standing behind you
they're looking at it going oh that's
funny understanding apart so they stay
sorry they sent these to me those are
your get more what do you mean you want
I could give a couple things away but
maybe I have doubles of the one we could
definitely give away shorter to hey kids
you want a movie you want some movie
shirts it's Jay sober birthday but we're
giving the gifts to you how about that
yes I like that one do we do a little
bit even more
yeah let's open that the other two will
save for next week yes this is from the
gun folks at Spin Master remember we
open stuff from them yes a couple months
back
and we did the commercials for the
Batman toys on the little spot that
we've been on Instagram so this is a box
and it's got some games and it's board
games we're gonna see what it is craw
craw for kill says kr four kills it says
please keep everything would much more
enjoy seeing the builds on the stream
than trying to win something I think
that's your best play bro that's good
advice
yeah but there are some stuff that are
double so you know maybe I like your
idea bro yes all right kids we got
another one to open rickety cast says I
can't get any movies please help I'm in
Pensacola Florida be patient within one
month your dreams will be answered all
right here we go this is first stop Oh
[ __ ] look at this man Avengers hero
rush game and it comes with a two chala
Tony and Bruce Bruce Banner man comes to
the Hulk black panther and iron man look
at those kids they're having the [ __ ]
time of their lives what is the idea all
the same two of them are the same but
there's other ones here so what's the
idea
it says move Marvel your two timers from
one section of the flip zone to another
score bonus tokens three tokens and you
score a victory
boom so looks like you got a foot tokens
one foot one flip zone three marbles
three timers 24 Avengers that meets 100
cards move Marvel your timers from one
section of the flip zone to another so
you got to get one to the nether and
score bonus tokens three tokens and you
score victory see
I don't think anything has ever made me
as happy as these three kids seem I know
right
paint bunkers are filled with so much
joy they're like oh my god I want to be
those kids that's real sweet what's the
other one and we got past the poop
[Applause]
[Music]
is a Friday night you know in Hollywood
so let's babble on I'm Kevin Smith
[Music]
laughs these animated kids drawing her
kids throwing [ __ ] around never thought
I'd live so long that you know in the
year 2020 you could just literally put a
picture of kids throwing [ __ ] at each
other
and that's how to sell the product you
know that make them a lot of people
scared too much on this one you want to
open this and see if that one works the
oppressor does it work it's so weird I
don't hear maybe it needs a battery acid
vaster you may not last contents one
musical poop 12 toilet paper tokens and
one instruction sheet I heard you write
requires it remove batteries for maybe
it's got one of those tags you know I
don't mean you could pass to poop to
each other but look at that man he's got
the weirdest eyebrows yeah I think it's
really disturbing that they included
like this they're like look at the
panties some boys underwear will be
filled with poop your y-fronts when you
play pass the boom mic a turn in your
crime fighters in that what you call the
underwear yeah all my best material I've
stolen from Jason Mewes we are at 1,350
two people watching live ladies and
gentlemen all here for Jason Mewes is
sober soberest of birthdays you can lose
this table yes come on up here and we'll
chit chat will answer questions and
we'll find out what the people what your
your people want from you man you hang
out with your people every day here on
Twitch Jay loves this twitch channel I
can't get them to do anything else
anymore
I was like let's make a Jane saw Bob
sequel he's like [ __ ] you am on twitch
she said he'd only do it if it was Jay
and Silent Bob or on twitch which would
be a cheap movie to make as larell says
hey guys
Elliott here Wow look at this Restless
Vita is gifting 50 tier one steps to the
community
Thank You Vita you scholar and a
gentleman hey guys Elliott here my baby
boy Oscar was born on the 30th of June
happy birthday little baby oscar already
shown them a little of Jane saw Bob haha
we're calling parent services on we're
calling diapers on it we're gonna st.
little Oscar I connect can I ask Kevin
and Jay for a blessing oh let me tell
you something in the name of the Father
the Son the Holy Spirit we bless you
little Oscar may you live to be a
thousand years mm-hmm
cosign well done again guys on making
yourselves better I don't know if we
made ourselves better but we're
definitely still here Slayer 1983's is
playing with your [ __ ] is gross Wow
don't knock it till you try it with pool
around the room man that kind nice
restless PETA is gifting 52017 Jamie is
good there they've gifted until the four
hundred in the channel over this whole
time yeah like eaten well less than a
year but like over the year he's gifted
four hundred subs so much Restless Vita
how do you know it's a guy oh and MJ
donated some money we don't see them out
um but thank you so much
starting bid for our movie shirt oh I
thought I liked it and it was your raid
is yours I don't know we should we track
this but I just don't know someone said
raid my bed as I missed it you guys like
the dad trying to put together kids to
us on Christmas morning right now it
says cannon fodder 1979 we are dads Oh
Vita I'm so sorry Belle I didn't realize
that you've already gifted maybe earlier
a hundred gift because you were not up
in the first tier 261 yeah yeah today
thank you and Bona needs to sorry
trademark thank you guys you guys are
all heroes thank you very very very much
rol OSC says can I get a no ticket no
ticket
I stole a BGN 1029 says I made a twitch
just for today thank you that's because
they want to see and they want to
celebrate thank you very much
Jay Mewes Bonin Easter says okay now
show him the Captain America infinity
Wars thing here that you forgot to show
him because I can't remember I've moved
everything and I have a place I'm trying
to place my figures
dimka 228 says heaven ji thanks a lot
for everything you do we really don't do
that much let's be honest the first time
when I watched your movies it was in
2005 when I was a kid and you motivated
me learning English hello from Russia
das is a Madani well that's good bye
hello I forget what hello is in Russian
hi but at the end it's done when you're
like da svidaniya that's when it's all
over hi we got a lot of fans in Russian
we've never been there we got to go over
there sooner or later men all the
countries that aren't next to California
let's see we got tea KBS's third June 30
is my birthday to CY 76 is I just saw
Ethan simply in the hunt fantastic movie
did you guys see it yet I did it was
really fun and Ethan was great he was
just on my podcast recently not was on
his infinity AR is gifting ten Tier one
subs to the community yeah Jason muses
thank you for that dave rocky says kevin
the scene from James I'll check back is
it true your daughter plays one of the
baby versions that's absolutely true
baby Silent Bob was played by baby
Harley Quinn in 2001 and Jay and Silent
Bob strike back she's playing baby me
baby sound book and then 18 years later
baby Silent Bob grew up to play Millie
in Jay and Silent Bob strike back
proving that if you stick around Kevin
Smith
that long enough you will go from a bit
part to a [ __ ] major lead you just
asked Jason Mewes oh look who it is
look who it is it's the little pink
sugar heart it's the little pink sugar
heart
come on over and say hi to the camera
everyone's looking and they look where
is she where's the little pink sugar
there she is
birthday joy in the arms of Jay what is
that yeah that's right kid cocky-doody
boo boo Boop Don Bautista he can't find
that figure he'll find it later on I'm
so sorry watch this tender of family
moment she this and I really I've moved
all my stuff and I'm having trouble
finding all my things I'm trying to I
told you I tried to clean watches that
we're out by remote yes do you want to
go back in the house proof that Jason
Mewes is had sex at least once dr. Yeoh
says hey there hey there hey there ice
volcano says my husband chance and I
have been watching you guys for years we
love you guys so much oh my god thank
you how sweet are you Mikayla there's
one more question Kevin when are you
gonna pitch the new Star Blazers now
that you have he-man under your belt
remember that cartoon of course I do
we're off to outer space we're leaving
Mother Earth to save the human race
Oh Star Blazers I remember it I don't
think they'll give it to me
they should probably give it to like a
big fan
remember battling planets as well let's
see what's your guys favorite movie says
ro L o SC and why is it Dogma what was
your guys favorite honestly I love
clerks too I love them all they're all
my kids but clerks - Jay and Silent Bob
reboot those are the ones that are
closest to my heart red state I think is
the best directed movie ever made tusk
is the most original most [ __ ] up and
stuff but Claire
- and reboot they're very very close in
the which we call it you know sorry I
got lost reading I forgot what I was
gonna say ah / 3d says I need to hear
music from clerks when you two are
standing outside of the store and Jay
does his sexy dance would you [ __ ] me
I'd [ __ ] me all from yes from clerks - I
think that is yes when he did the the
buffalo bill tuck dance when he talked
what else we got going on here man I'm
by myself in this [ __ ] I'm Jason muses
sober birthday now cap Smith's unsub or
birthday man a very Merry on sober
birthday to me
I can't smoke weed in here though cuz I
don't want smoke them out but I will
when I get home and are you cats
interested in a little fat man beyond
because I'm heading over to the
closed-down scum and villainy Cantina
because Los Angeles just got closed down
again and me and Mark Barnard will be
doing fat man beyond tonight at 7
o'clock over at my youtube channel and
in my facebook and the scum and villainy
channels and whatnot so if you want to
hear me and Mark talk about all the
latest happenings in the world of comic
books including Ray Fisher's tweet wow
man we'll probably be talking about it
tonight on fat man beyond 7 o'clock on
my youtube channel ok breezy dropped TV
says I'm 30 got you guys have inspired
me since I was a kid I love Dogma Thank
You breezy two-foot Giants as Jay wanted
to thank you for doing a micro interview
on my juice review a couple of years ago
in Houston the vape summit walkway I
will tell him you said thanks he just
[ __ ] off he's abandoned his feed which
was allowed me to take it over man I was
already working today we shot the
celebrity show off which is a show that
I'm on on TBS right now I'm making a
little show in the show called Sun and
lockdown with my family and stuff so we
did the we shot the show today we're not
the little short but the show where you
watched a little short the the
our version of met airs on TBS Tuesdays
at 10 o'clock I believe it is so I was
at 10 o'clock 10:15 I was sitting in
front of a remote-controlled camera with
a monitor so I could see everybody else
and nobody else in the room and so if
you ever watched the show we're all in
our little screens that's that's kind of
how it's done it's been fun though I
love Megan Sun in lockdown it's almost
like going back to film school you know
in many ways because clerks was like the
first literally the first thing I ever
did I didn't make any short films before
that was my first thing so I never had
an experimental period where I got to
train and try things out and stuff so as
we're doing Sun in lockdown like you
know all that from from Mallrats forward
we always had a crew and a continuity
person and a DP who knows eye lines and
so something as simple is like not
knowing the eye lines not crossing the
axis
I'm retraining through all that now
because we don't have a full crew it's
just like me my family and Josh and Liv
and Josh's shooting so you know josh is
like shoots well but he don't want to be
a DP he wants be a director so the two
of us trying to figure out like eye
lines and [ __ ] has been really fun man
it's legit fun making the shorts and I
think it's because there's no [ __ ]
no is just like us and then we get to
watch it you know on the TBS channel on
their YouTube channel and stuff and it's
been fun man so so far so good we've
shot four they've aired well I mean
three have been online and the fourth
one we just shot the other day so
hopefully I get to make it close to the
end if not all the way to the end man
our Jimmy 1989 says I've seen most year
movies but never saw a dog until a month
ago and loved it thank you sir
I love Dogma we're gonna have some news
on that soon he winked let's see Stephen
Hendricks 123 says you all need to do a
euro trip brother you ain't kiddin you
ain't kiddin I think all of us would
love to go to Europe right now it sounds
great although I hear they got covert
over there as well as soon as they allow
too
kids will back out there Turin man
that's what we do we love being in front
of the audience and stuff look I'll be
honest with you we love taking the money
yes that goes without saying
but we love interacting with the
audience it for me it's a hoot to walk
out and see thousand fifteen hundred
people even 200 people sitting there
going ah right [ __ ] talk to us
so that'll never go away unless they're
like we can't find a cure a vaccine so
nobody's ever allowed to have an
audience again if that's the case then
we bid farewell to our live stuff but as
soon as they let us as soon as they
could find a cure for this stuff as soon
as like you know if there's any
breathing room literally we'll be back
over there man
I wanna go I've been wanting to John's
is weird but jonesing to go to
Manchester Manchester my favorite city
over there and I had a great time last
time I was there with the Hollywood
babble-on tour right after we finished
shooting Jay and Silent Bob reboot me
and Ralph went and did a Hollywood
babble-on
tour in the UK then I had one day down
because it was pretty consistent to her
and that free dad just went to
Manchester and had the best [ __ ] time
man unions great [ __ ] people there's
[ __ ] wonderful as Canadians its Mach
3 a says I'll never forget seeing clerks
2 in theatres right on thank you
means the world yeah I'll never forget
making it the shadow the shadow says my
Stanley memory met Stanley four to five
times in a ten-year span very first time
I got an autograph and photo op after
the photo op he said there now we're
immortalized how sweet we all loved Stan
particularly in this house we're big
fans he was such a great guy my mentor
know best
I'm afraid I've met the best person I'll
ever meet in my life and I'm afraid he
passed away but I was lucky to have met
him at all James Sparrow says huge fan I
remember back in the day when zack and
miri had a screening at if i brought my
mom who had no clue who y'all were but
that movie made her a huge fan of all
your stuff number one thank you how
adorable you brought your mom but number
two I remember that screening the
midnight screening because we were in
the midnight section that's
I know that you're the Toronto
International Film Festival what a great
screening that was when I was like this
second Miri movie might do business and
then it did Kevin Smith business made
like 30 million and stuff but still we
had Seth Rogen done so much more and
that's not his fault I don't think we
were marketed properly or maybe the
movie wasn't good enough or whatever but
it's I love that picture and you know
you get to see his dick in it yes
generates guys his big fan of you guys
seen every episode of comic book men at
least twice I'm aspiring filmmaker
filmmaker and appreciate the good vibes
you guys put out in the universe why
thank you that means a lot man
the good vibes come from having a friend
above-ground
who you know kicked his habit if you
will kicked it right in the [ __ ]
balls and stole his life back somebody
went when Logan came in Koala cast he
said oh my [ __ ] god it's the star
reboot Logan yeah she was wonderful in
that flow um okay how I kept Jason 23
says any update on the Hollywood
babble-on archives being released and
happy birthday Jason beaches I think
Ralph is organizing that and putting it
together it's a tech thing but he's got
them all now so soon you'll be able to
see him they won't be on that Kevin
Smith Club kids if you want to come hang
out with me at that Kevin Smith Club I'd
love it back Kevin Smith club.com but
all the babylons will be at the ralph
report so if you're a Ralph report
subscriber you're gonna be getting those
pretty soon if they're not already out
ranting Andy says Jay Mewes and Kevin
Smith happy ten years sober happy
birthday to you happy birthday to you
happy birthday George a happy birthday
to you and many more i Kevin Smith just
wanted to say I saw you on Match Game
you were awesome thank you and you were
match and you were match game question
probably one of the best shows ever and
of course you had on the purple jacket I
did I don't remember the question was
about comic books and shaving a symbol
into your chest all of the answers were
s but of course I chose the Batman
symbol nice yes
great answer I don't think it worked out
though for the contestant if I remember
correct
Rinka chaos is it Kevin can me and my
son get a shout out I'm fat man beyond
we watch you every time and I will sell
and it will you sell me a prop from your
movie I like I need like a golden piece
from my collection as a lot of asks
rickety we could probably handle them
all I'm not gonna bomb I smoke so much
weed I will not remember that I'm
supposed to give you a shout-out by the
time I go to that other show at 7
o'clock tonight so no promises there man
I'm doing fat man beyond this is
important we talked about doing a live
show for your [ __ ] 10 years sober
birthday was gonna be huge was gonna be
the biggest show we ever did at one
point literally we were talking about
maybe Radio City Music Hall and we would
have been able to sell it out it's such
a marketable [ __ ] hook ten years
[ __ ] sober would have been amazing so
the least we could do is come hang out
here and let's see waken her once is keV
I just got diagnosed with some serious
cardiac issues an aneurism and a faulty
valve nothing to [ __ ] with so listen to
your doctor eliten which will probably
require surgery probably and soon I'm
telling you right now to look for me to
shout out to you in chat on fat man
beyond this coming August you'll
remember me because I'll remind you that
I used to date the yo-yo lady from Ohio
if you remember that I do remember the
yo-yo lady wow you dated her that's not
to me
watch your heart too good carrier your
heart there go slow
listen to what they tell you because
that's the battery without that so be
careful man I feel for you as somebody
who also has heart problems art disease
we're in the club but our our hearts
won't [ __ ] kill us well will will be
in charge
don't you worry everything's gonna be
all right cocky jerk I was just calling
Jay that cocky jerk says Kevin could I
make a request for the new smog castle
new smog castle will be opening in the
fall now I hope Jersey still shut down
but Ernie O'Donnell doing a great job on
spot castle building it out can't wait
to do shows there could you possibly
bring back highlands of people history
for a his episode or two as a podcast
that did with Walt Bry we also did it
with Jay I really enjoyed that podcast
when you talk about growing up
your friends in Jersey thanks from a
mall rat on that Kevin Smith Club thank
you for joining that Kevin Smith Club
you better [ __ ] believe when we do
squad castle we're doing Highlands of
people history now you got to remember
when we used to do it live we did a lot
of a few times at the smog Castle we're
talking to a bunch of people don't know
Highlands a jersey and show would go
well but imagine doing that show in
Leonardo that's where the new smart
castles gonna be right in the quick stop
building so you're doing Highlands
people history there everyone knows Han
Lance
so that'd be amazing for sure Oh it'll
be wonderful so the s we will be doing
that all right man pseudo Grace's since
you were in a die hard movie my last
name is McClane
could I please get a McClane shout out
it would make my year thanks Michael
McClane I'll be honest with you Michael
you're my favorite MacLean there I said
all right what do you want to do now man
is your birthday
justice fight we get tried it I mean I
think mall brought the bomber with more
broads it really frustrates me there is
no bummer with mahlberg there isn't but
I'm saying I really want us to get past
that you know that you wind up fighting
someone told me somewhere on here
nobody's here today he's gotten past the
carts to the hockey goalie I guess for
tamaki then you played the [ __ ] monster
then you fight [ __ ] so we got places to
go a lot of places so we could do let's
draw brawl it well I say we mob well we
keep it on Brandon Jay and Silent Bob
well done on in 10 years to spiff and
walk - I'm two weeks since I picked up a
joint and I'm dying ha ha would donate
both balls to meet you - my fave
director ever and Jay is just a legend
in his self sorry for simple that's not
simple that's just telling the truth all
right get that game get that game I come
to play mall bro
I mean [ __ ] your birthday I came to play
ma bra even you are not denying me the
mall bro
papa Bubba once again hearts go out to
the friends and fans family of Byron
Bernstein men I always want to say
reckless but it's reck fold that was the
funny part of that name and if you know
anybody that struggling kids if you know
anybody that's feeling down stuff like
that like reach out you have no idea how
much a simple conversation will do for
some folks listen to that the sound of
pure joy I'm gonna break a sweat playing
this game I'll tell you that how do i
how do I message the dynamic duo to just
shout out on a message I got says at
Atlas Silent Bob will shout y'all right
now what's up all right man d JC Mike 1
7 16 says Kevin I was eating at ashes
that was an old restaurant in Red Bank
New Jersey right next to the stash for
lunch one day with my dad right next to
it of Jay and Silent Bob's secret stash
well while eating lunch your wife and
her friend happened to be at the bar
eating lunch so I told the bartender
Mike at the time I will pick up their
tab my dad looks at me and asked why I
just picked up their tab and I said well
one day I might be doing an acting
audition and well I hope that when I
tell him that story he might give me the
part my dad said but he has more money
than me and you combined your dad was
right don't ever pay for you know
[ __ ] a quote-unquote rich person's
food and stuff I don't consider myself
rich but I can't pay for a meal and I
know I can pay for my wife's meal is
incredibly sweet of you thank you for
that and I'm not bullshitting I honestly
think I remember this cuz it was one of
the first times in our lives where she
was like you have fans somebody paid for
food we had my kids christening party at
ashes after she got baptized so thank
you for some fun wonderful memories man
shall we do it big panda 2 2 3 says hey
congratulations on max reload that's a
movie that's coming out folks that I'm
in about gaming an old friend from high
school worked on that with you oh right
on man
Greg Grunberg got me into that Conan
ista says there's an extra bird who
gains energy being around other people
between not working not going anywhere
it gets tough I would imagine man like
you know I'm I have been in quarantine
locked down with somebody like the whole
time obviously with my wife and my kids
there and her boyfriend and Byron and
Gail and Jason's around the block and
stuff but what happens to the cats that
like don't have some how do you turn
this down what do you you know what if
you're somebody that doesn't have
somebody like around and stuff I would
imagine it gets very difficult so yeah
keep keep looking out for folks look out
for your friends if you haven't heard
from people in wild it's give a shout
done wrong [ __ ] and I know we live
in a texting generation where you know
it's like I've much rather write to
somebody than speak to them on the phone
is weird cuz when we grew up it was all
about being on the phone our parents
were always like get off the [ __ ]
phone you're tying up the line and [ __ ]
like that and now years later you can't
get anybody on the phone nobody wants to
talk on the phone well you make them
talk on the phone particularly during
this time don't leave anybody behind
too much loneliness out there right now
it's a bummer about reckful wonderboy
says hey keV do you still have a giant
[ __ ] off TV in your room in my bedroom I
do still there 103 inches god when it
dies it's gonna suck I don't know how
the hell we're gonna get out of the
house it's like big as a car you got it
Jay Meister 5 says hey Kevin Jay just
got done watching the reboot last night
I have to say that for you Kevin it was
your magnum opus
I agree thank you so much it doesn't
mean it was the best thing I ever made
but it's definitely the epic of my life
story of my life and movie people loved
seeing everyone from the Buick universe
after all these years you must be in
England that's where like people are
seeing it streaming right now for the
first time can't wait to see what you
guys come up with next twilight of the
Mallrats
AKA Mallrats - also happy silver
birthday J love you guys stay safe out
there did you get it to work crazy lady
car says happy and sad I just found this
stream know about the Pampa ban we I
should have options two players Jay
Mewes remember the two of you in this
video in the lower right corner it
sometimes blocks the game Bonin eesti
says me tell you son Bonin ease I doubt
we're even gonna get to play at a game
he's got one [ __ ] job twitch any no
other mic no other control he's [ __ ]
selfish happy selfish silver birthday
rickety chaos ass will you all ever be
on Rick and Morty [ __ ] I hope so oh my
god I love that show
I think Joe I think Justin is like a
legitimately hysterical actor and you
know the solar opposites performance
bears that out as far as I'm concerned I
mean think about it and Rick amore talks
to himself
I'm genius is that and sounds like two
different people hey cab says Restless
Mita
Kevin hey man the video conference AMA
you did with your club members was
awesome thank you we'll be doing that
again I'm hoping to be able to do that
like at least twice a month if not four
times once a week I was up next but will
said he tried to throw me in for the
next one definitely for sure man we'll
get you up there for the chitchat and
like I said we do more per month at that
Kevin Smith cloud like one a week then
we'll get everybody but everybody has a
better chance of getting covered let me
see
shiner snaps says I've watched
everything you've ever made and saw you
in Austin last year so glad to see you
doing well working on masters universe
keep up the amazing work my lord how
kind you're very very sweet let me check
the time 438 you can't find the
controller I was just looking at
somebody my Twitter stream put up a
video of this mom he's got she's got a
boy little boy with CP I think cerebral
palsy so but he always wanted to
skateboard which I guess would be hard
for him or impossible so the mom built
this rig it's so [ __ ] beautiful and
make you cry she built this rig where
it's got cables that kind of keep him up
yeah and put him in it and then he can
stand on the skateboard and she took him
to a skate park I'm gonna cry talking
about she took him to a skate park and
like a lead stuff wheeled around and
[ __ ] for her boy come on man there's so
much [ __ ] beauty in the world you know
a lot of misery and ugliness too but a
lot of beauty as well
never forget that folks Mike Sparrow
have you written with Dan Harmon I'd be
curious to see what that looks like I
have not written with anybody but Dan
seems very serious about the craft of
writing he's very into three-act
structure story a circle and stuff like
that which they kind of did on a recent
episode so I bet you he would be annoyed
by me because I don't I don't do
classical structure storytelling I just
like oh this will be fun oh this would
be cool are we doing it yes go greased
lightnin
what are we doing oh [ __ ] there it is so
we're about to play finally in a minute
there's me what about you I saw a little
movement sold and says in Seoul is
spelled like Seoul Korea I've been a fan
since Siskel and Ebert reviewed clerks
and got my young butt to remember the
name and rent it that was a great review
I remember that man
I remember watching that review excites
to watch Siskel and Ebert all the time
and so when we finally got reviewed on
the movie on their show oh my god
astounding what's going on here music
stops did you friends have a sleepover
put up a fight at first cuz it was in
black and white laughter our little
asses off you're still the best stay
cool thank you Seoul ban that means the
world man
vegan mom in 1995 says one of my
childhood friends who is now a game
developer and did the game the Stanley
parable now works with Justin roiland
and it's awesome it's nice to see people
you grew up with become successful I
agree I'm friends with a guy who grew up
to be very successful when people are
like do you know famous people I'm like
lucky at Jay Mewes Jay Mewes Bonin ista
says Russell Brand is doing zooms with
fans on Wednesday as part of a self-help
thing since he's also clean and sober
for 20 years 20 plus years and part of
program is to be in support groups and
have mentors how awesome I love Russell
he's been in my house he's been on spod
casts he's a lovely dude I remember he
was at my house when he first started
dating Carrie Katy Perry I think one of
the reasons he came to do the podcast my
house is Katy Perry lives in my
neighborhood I mean she must we'd go to
the same voting polling station
so um you know he was like I love this
girl it was really sweet I mean I was a
muse and years ago and stuff but uh he's
such a smart guy oh my god to be as
smart well-read thus entered as Russell
Brand
I wish did you guys have an Atari game
night yeah it says creepy Thin Man not
yet
it's all I asked for maybe I'll get it
from my sober birthday what are you
looking for back there
ocular ferret says it is fun with a
pacemaker defibrillator when you work
and cannot breathe and take and test Oh
for heart failure and you get a lot of
dizziness take care you do not want this
I don't I really don't I don't want a
pacemaker that's for sure here let's
turn this down since nobody's playing or
anything I you know I here I'll tell you
what the other day my whole [ __ ] life
was Jason Mewes Jason Mewes never shied
away from telling you what he would like
during a holiday so around Christmas
he's like ooh this is what I like and
around his birthday is that gu this is
what I want and I appreciate that
because then it's not guesswork yeah
this sweet new monitor I got it for his
real birthday that just passed in June
so the other day I like realized that I
wanted something and so I texted Jay and
I was like I know what you can get me
for my birthday
and he was so delighted as a clue
finally help and I said get me a
Nintendo switch is that what it's called
yes get me that Nintendo switch I says
like an old man who doesn't know the
name of it I said cuz I want to be able
to play this [ __ ] game I don't wanna
have to come over here all the time to
play it I'm not some poor kid from
Highlands like I was back in the 70s and
80s and [ __ ] I could buy my own damn
video games but I would like to him to
give me the Nintendo switch so because I
know they're hard to find and be
frustrating try to go find one now have
you had any luck tracking one down
I'm just waiting to see guys maybe you
guys know what's better I've never
personally tried out the new then I know
it as a turtle crowd ball said hey Kevin
unbox Jail working controller [ __ ] yeah
man
say Pia superior seed says Jay has
discovered that power comes from the
high ponytail top knot he has become a
top knot [ __ ] isn't he like no
matter you should seen him on the road
when we were doing the reboot or there's
always this big ball of hair right up
top and stuff what happened you don't
like it being long no more you know
slays says my name is pronounced slays
similar to blazed or haze would you be
able to give a shout out to my cousin
who is a huge huge fan bears birthday as
well
happy birthday mighty Miller from where
from Michigan when I don't know how to
say when I Wyandotte so I'll just say
Michigan happy birthday Mikey Miller
from Michigan Mikey Miller from Michigan
has allowed alliteration
when are we getting another Jay and
Silent Bob get old you're gonna get a
home show very soon and we're also gonna
do one I think streaming kind of like
this but pop maybe not on Twitch we'll
see but we're gonna do it we are going
to do it have to where is 10 year sober
birthday the mic I usually use I have a
Nashville mic I mean controller I have a
scope controller I have been ps4
controller an Xbox controller I tried
all four of them for some reason easy I
plug it in it registers and we're good
to go
I don't not this time but the one I
usually use I don't I can't find and I
can't imagine that will make a
difference but the one I usually use is
like around and I usually grab it and we
plug it in I don't know what so we could
yes [ __ ] fell apart viewers are dropping
like flies like [ __ ] this I could play a
game what the [ __ ] are we doing and [ __ ]
I heard a ding what does that mean ding
Emily em fly 12 times a cab
Jakob Cotner says my wife Ashley made
the felt dolls I love them I think you
guys are talking to Don about doing them
at the stash they're waiting for you at
the office on vine that's where they are
we love you guys Congrats Jay so they
went to the [ __ ] office yes we'll
send somebody over to get him if they
let us back in the building man like you
know I think our building has been shut
down for a while still American 1269 one
says Kevin of love and Jay and Silent
Bob is wrong I don't want to be right
pac-man Minnesota or MN says quote Jay
Mewes I usually grab it and plug it in
and he said and that's how Logan came to
be
oh [ __ ] man
Styria laws says lay the podium down you
were there
holy [ __ ] you were there at the Roy
Thompson Hall show I mean you've got to
be from there in order to know that what
is this this just popped us when are we
getting a walrus an action figure says
James Brown I know we need some tusks
stuff right I always wanted a plushy
tusks like a little stuffed walrus with
all the scars all over [ __ ] yeah you can
butcher of men butcher of Mans is Kevin
how are your turtles doing since tanked
it they're good they're chillin man but
chillin they used to have fish in the
tank but they start going after the fish
and now it's just the Turtles mr. muse
did you grow your 70s porno mustache for
a movie or for the hell that's this
formerly screaming gremlin you know what
it started to grown I got a little lazy
and it started to get thicker and
thicker
said oh my gosh I think it's almost what
is this gg Mike 11:16 says let's get Jay
some sponsors cab what are sponsors like
for your channel the guy got some stuff
sent to me HyperX my keyboard my headset
Astro sent me a pair of headsets you
know but who is anything it's more about
one I gotta keep track of my stuff
very sweet Dollface ninety gave a shout
out and said very nice things to Jay
there uh there's something I just read
and it just went away but where was oh
oh oh gee samurai killer says never
forget when warlock ran five generators
just to stay online in the middle of a
fire sale that was from plugging live
free or die hard like I'm rocking five
generators just to stay online well I
could sit here and just read questions
all day I love it so much you kids have
a good time here on Jays sober birthday
10 years and counting
ladies and gentlemen we gotta kill this
music and again it's a bummer guys I'm
sorry Kevin could I mean I'd love to see
Kevin could always try to play a little
skipping dipping by himself but he does
have a show tonight
I will be skippity dipa ting by myself
as a matter of fact I just got a text
from somebody at mo - hey Kevin do you
happen to have yeah like please don't
give those away I'm like oh [ __ ]
let me see Kevin do you happen to have
the FT the final draft file for the 105
cut down that was done in late April
here's the PDA yes gimme
fifteen mins
put that [ __ ] in my hand look at you you
saw me at work literally at work on
masters of the universe right there this
is a very special day kids and we're all
here for this very special day with a
very special man without whom none of us
would be here you wouldn't be sitting
here watching this channel without Jack
I wouldn't be sitting here in Hollywood
in California without Jay James the
rocket sauce that got us here man like
[ __ ] is very rarely in life do you
meet a true American original and I met
one and instantly hitched my wagon to
star and here we are man in in 10 years
of sobriety think about all you've done
you've traveled the world doing shows
everywhere you've become a adept public
speaker a rock on tour if you will
used to be like to go watch the old
evening Kevin Smith's I'd be like
welcome Jason Mewes not bring him out
and be like reserved then he goes to
knock couch and say nothing for two
hours so he ain't that guy anymore man
he's made [ __ ] multiple movies he's
we did Jay and Silent Bob reboot we've
done Jay and Silent Bob good old and our
relationship grew closer over the course
of the last 10 years because the drugs
weren't a factor you didn't have to
worry about him
imploding or exploding or something like
that so it has been everything Jay is
you know everyone says like you're such
a good friend to him and you stuck
around what a good friend why would I
leave you meet a true American original
true original never minds from America
but he is from America true New Jersey
original and you want to be around that
person Jay has only made my life better
and yes there were times when he was a
drug user that like he made his life
worse and that of course trickled into
other lives but he's only been a
positive a whole good in my life so
special such a special person that I
think if I had not met him and we didn't
hook up and start making the movies I
honestly don't think I'd be here today I
don't think clerks would be what it is
and stuff like that
yeah that's that's who that kid is and I
said it at the beginning show them I say
it one more time
think of what you love to do and how
much you love doing it and now imagine
somebody
like you can't do that imagine if it's
not just something like I wish I could
do something you do do too like [ __ ]
let off steam [ __ ] you know have a
good time and [ __ ] like that imagine if
somebody said you can't do that for the
rest of your life if you want to be
around us you can't do what makes you
feel good in life how you let your steam
on out and stuff like that every day
this [ __ ] makes that choice and
you saw it a little kid that he brought
in here before
that's easy now to make the choice
because he's got someone who looks up to
him and loves him a [ __ ] like that
but when he started this journey 10
years ago this 10 years of sobriety that
we celebrate today there were no
guarantees there he didn't know he was
gonna have a kid he didn't know that
there'd be something to live for and
stuff like that he did it out of a sense
of love for those around him for his
wife for his friend or friends but like
not for himself is ain't a selfish act
that he did in saving his life over the
course of 10 years the beauty of this is
he did it brothers you know yes he does
it for himself as well but left to his
own devices he probably wouldn't have
but because he loves the people in his
life because he loves Jordan because he
loves me he put that [ __ ] monster to
the side think about that man like they
think about like the thing that you're
like nobody's taking this away from me
he took it away from himself makes him a
[ __ ] hero without that we don't get
to be doing this today and you know
years ago I was uneducated about
addiction so I would just be like stop
doing drugs as if it was that [ __ ]
easy and stuff and ten years later after
I mean he's been sober for ten years I
know how difficult is I know how hard is
I know it's hard when I'm on a 72-hour
fast and I'm not eating food and I'm
like I just wanna [ __ ] eat that food
so bad and [ __ ] so I applaud you my
friend you are everything and everything
is you you continue to impress me
there's no end of the surprises that
come from you and now they're all good
surprises not shitty surprises I had a
blast touring with Jason when we were on
tour last year it was such a good time
we got to hang out together like an old
married couple and stuff like that but
he is like shy of like my my wife and my
kid the most
important person in my life and he I
knew him before I knew my wife and my
kid we go all the way back to Highlands
New Jersey and because of this
[ __ ] from Highlands New Jersey
both of us have footprints and
handprints in the forecourt of the
Chinese Theater they didn't put me there
because I'm like director Kevin Smith
they're like your director they put me
in the ground in the best possible way
because of Jay and Silent Bob and there
is no Jay and Silent Bob without the man
sitting to my right ladies and gentleman
give it up for the sober birthday boy
himself mr. Jason Mewes you're amazing I
can't believe we're at this day I'm so
happy for you I'm so glad you didn't
[ __ ] I'm so glad the [ __ ] that you
said when you were younger about like if
I'm still this way at 30 you don't even
have to think about any more men it's
means the world to me means the world to
these people
anyone that liked Jay and Silent Bob
reboot or madness in the method that had
everything to do with my man getting
clean and sober and stuff like that if
you like his stream if you like Jay and
Silent Bob get old if you like to watch
him on make Legos and [ __ ] like that or
mega constructs now that he's got those
that's because he makes the choice every
day to to be here with us in the present
and [ __ ] like that thank you for that
that means the world to me
happy birthday you deserve everything in
so much more ladies and gentlemen I give
you back to the host of your stream mr.
Jason Mewes man thank you for hanging
out with us your how long you're doing
this just say goodbye I don't need to
walk him to his car but I always like to
say goodbye so I'm gonna I usually put
on like I'll put on some more what's in
the box and then I'm gonna come back and
we're gonna give some goodies away yeah
save that orange shirt for who is it who
want to wrestle spoiler bounine Easter I
usually put on kids thanks for hanging
out this has been [ __ ] fun remember
I'll be on
Fatman beyond tonight with mark barnard
on my youtube channel seven o'clock
PST Pacific time because I think it's 7
o'clock
Easter Eddie isn't it yeah it is it's
past seven o'clock so yes look for me
and in two two hours two hours over at
fat man be gone
meantime I'm gonna put this on guys and
then I'm gonna mute the mic and say
goodbye hold on before you go says 80s
else I'm about sober moment June 14th
we lost Damian Mets who Koz played sorry
Koz played as the neon halo wearing
buddy Christ that's right I saw that
dude who was always playing buddy Christ
cosplay his buddy Christ for over 14
years at the comic-con met uks wearing
the neon halo and a beloved gem at
DragonCon
can you please could you share a rest in
peace moment for Damien Damien mattes
ladies gentlemen played buddy cry see
cosplay buddy Christ and he passed away
I'd read that on Twitter men so let's
just take a moment of silence rest in
peace Dan Dame Damien sorry Damien Mets
oh my god can't ask a guy to rest in
peace without somebody else's name rest
in peace Damien Mets a moment of silence
for Damien Mets
our buddy Christ there it is enjoy your
day kids I give you back well he's gonna
walk out with me and then later on back
with Jason Mewes don't go anywhere he's
gonna be playing some games and doing
[ __ ] giving away goodies
you